ce père et mentor vous allez l'exclure
du front national le parti qu'il a fondé
et dont il a voulu retirer son propre
nom c'était en 2015
et je peux dire que j'ai honte que le
président dise la présidente du front
national porte mon nom et je
souhaiterais d'ailleurs qu'elle ne perde
plus rapidement possible elle peut le
faire soit en se mariant avec son
concubin soit peut-être avec monsieur
philippe audet quelqu'un d'autre et moi
je fait pas que la présidente du front
national s'appelle le pen c'est d'une
violence
oui il est capable d'être il est capable
d'être très violent quand il est
contredit quand il est blessé aussi je
pense je pense qu'il a été très blessée
par cette situation honnêtement il m'a
pas tellement laissé le choix je pouvais
pas faire autrement il était entré dans
un processus de provocation à mon égard
qui faisaient que il était dans une
démarche de sabotage en fait de ce que
je souhaitais faire de ce que les les
adhérents en fait du front national
aussi me demandait de faire parce que je
leur ai proposé quelque chose ils m'ont
dit oui et non il avait du mal à le
supporter et quand quand il est blessé
il peut être terriblement brutale et
terriblement violent dans les propos
qu'il exprime mais voilà c'est son
caractère il est comme ça il a il a des
qualités il ya des revers de médaille
quoi
rancunier très rancunier ou capable de
s'adoucir avec les années il n'est pas
rancunier il n'est pas rancunier est
pour ça qu il a pardonné d'ailleurs à
son ex femme non il n'est pas rancunier
je ne suis pas non plus d'ailleurs
non c'est vraiment un des traits de
caractère qui n'a pas d'ailleurs il a
pardonné à tout le monde y compris à des
gens à qui il aurait pu lui pardonner
pour le coup tout au long de sa carrière
non il n'a pas il n'a pas ce défaut là
mais c'est vrai qu'il est capable
d'avoir des mots il sait exactement où
taper pour avoir les mots les plus les
plus blessants
qui soit
[Musique]